hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to some IO games now I've
played a ton of io games in the past and
you guys have probably played an IO game
for yourself such as agario slow very oh
boo vo vo either way there is a whole
website dedicated to these games that
I've already told you about IL games dot
space holds of LIF fora prefer a
plethora and virgilian there's [ __ ] a
bajillion of these so you got IL games
out the wazoo and I'm gonna play some of
them that I haven't played before
because this is another location where
indie game development is thriving not
only are people making tons of these but
tons and tons of people are playing this
and they're all variations of some games
you already probably know like the first
one that I'm gonna try here is one that
I've actually played before it's zoms IO
but now because everything needs a
battle royale mode it's oh this is the
game and what's probably gonna happen is
what's probably gonna happen when I play
any battle royale game is I'm gonna die
horribly and embarrass myself but you
guys are probably gonna be better than I
am so when you play this for yourself
you'll have a fun time oh my god oh this
is much smoother oh that's much better
oh look at that look I actually have a
body oh I'm free-falling I think am I
free fallin I don't know am i free
fallin okay
no no that's No Let Me In how do I get
in this oh no a pistol I'm gonna be
still oh I only got a piece stuff there
good nothing I'm gonna punch you I'm
gonna punch you get ready to be planche
you ready for pension oh if I walk
directly hey you
picked up all those guns in yet you're
not doing nothing okay well I guess you
didn't want to kill me oh boy I probably
doomed
oh no no no not me not me what about all
these no what about all this books again
[ __ ] five all right we got this
watch this what's this [ __ ] forget we're
here we're I can't believe I'm still
alive
I don't know how very much still alive
[Music]
pull okay where'd you go I did it you
got lots of bows to this thing it's good
good there's a lot of like that untrust
that this seems seems tricky dicky that
doesn't seem to be correct but oh [ __ ]
okay oh I've been killed
[ __ ] okay not bad but not great but
definitely in the IAO category of games
it works surprisingly well I'm good I
think well that's not a good sign
grenade perfect you and I are gonna have
a conversation
[ __ ] come on okay I'm going for it we
don't know where I'm going
whoa golden chest holy [ __ ] yes this
looks important
oh yeah yeah oh that's right
got him yeah I got a player hello
you've got a what if you got there who's
got there nope yes suck it suck it suck
it I got you from the death that's what
I call what I beat you from the grave I
got it from my own death [ __ ] you it
makes me feel good and you feel bad I
don't know I don't want you to feel bad
I want everyone to be happy that's all
I've ever wanted I'm going over this way
ammo
say I don't need I can't pick up ammo if
I don't have a gun apparently ice
problem has a big problem woof ha I
eliminated suck it that doesn't seem
right I'm a high denier they'll never
find me oh yeah that's good stuff that's
the good stuff if I just stay hidden in
here no one will find me right that's
how this works
Wow oh you didn't find me anymore I've
got a rocket that's very nice whoo that
looks pretty fancy I don't know if it's
good but I got a lot of rockets off me
use the rocket oh hello that's
surprisingly effective hmm oh I already
have a rockin show that one's better
than the whoops hello nope miss that
well that's problem all right hang on
what's this
okay all right well here's somewhere now
okay there's only 12 people left I'm one
of the last I want top ten baby I'm just
gonna fire rockets willy-nilly feel good
about myself not now Donna look look
look oh okay maybe Rockets weren't the
best idea maybe they weren't where we're
coming in from I see well let's go as
far as we can
perfect everything down here is gonna be
mine all mine
perfect I got a throwing star no one's
gonna stop me now oh yeah oh oh yeah
let's go for this sure okay I got a big
rocket launcher and I ain't afraid to
use it
I'm not sure what the ninja stars do but
I'm gonna go for that I see they're very
deadly yes yes yes ow
I am very much close to death please
have some sort of a healing who'll nope
that's not Hayley who all right well I
can only hope that I can blast someone's
ass oh hello you going for in here [ __ ]
oh god damn it okay
all right so that's not bad not bad okay
so this one's topping the popular list
at the moment it's called brutally oh
and I don't know how good it's whoa I
don't know why I don't okay what what is
this I'm a car with a flail on my ass I
don't know what that wow I got what kind
of giant testicle do you have no you
know I'm just really swinging oh boy you
work oh okay sure
that doesn't make a lot of sense but I'm
clicking now which is a thing it's new
and improv thing I think I'm missing a
core competence style dude I don't fully
understand the the mechanics oh [ __ ]
okay so you click to release and you
click again ah you click and hold to
bring it back to you right ok almost had
you there hope ok there ah yes I do
[Music]
funny thing [ __ ] oh jeez alright okay
this is tough like this just the
mechanics of it are super wonky it's
like oh man this is that kind of thing
where there's a huge skill gap where you
could be really good at it but also it's
really really hard to get into okay I
can reattach it and then I can fling it
full speed oh boy okay I deleted
somebody but I think it was purely
accidental okay
oh you're big I've got you oh it's
frozen uh think yeah I think that's
clearly I think that's clearly gonna be
me killing you I don't know
wait am i streaming oops wait no you
guys aren't supposed to see this okay
all right
oops [ __ ] oops I was accident good
thing I didn't bring up all my new
alright sorry let's continue this game
this is wonderful game
have no idea how to play Oh oh wait no
I'm dead ah your big swinging ball oh
this is just the game of big giant
swinging balls okay oh man I'm starting
to get the hang of it I'm starting to
get the hang of the nuances of the
nimble who got unnamed I guess yeah okay
there's there's definitely a nuance to
this a very good if I wasn't lagging so
much there's a very clever nuance to it
because it's like the angle of your
trajectory combined with the momentum of
your giant swinging ball combined with
the hilarity of the fact that you are
literally throwing your testicle at
people there is the nuance is incredible
oh hi apparently I did I did good oh oh
you capacities and then you inject your
testicle
ramming up the balls okay deleted new
boo-boo
come on Kinect I can't connect to my
ball Flitz I just need to connect to my
ball please thank you oh man these guys
are these guys are really eyeballing my
sack here oh boy that could easily kill
me what is not today that's so good
I could see how people could really get
into this one because it's like oh god
you got annihilated oh man
okay so there's definitely a strategy of
just going about and then flinging
you're getting your yeah I don't know
deleted but they must have been
impressive yeah there's definitely a
strategy to just kind of flinging your
you're enormous
okay alright then one more time throw my
tail quota
yeah the tail yeah this is there's
definitely a tail everybody yeah these
are these your tails I I got somebody
with total skill
[Music]
alright man
it's definitely hard to get start well
[ __ ] oh that guy's smart he's just
pushing his testicle I wish I could push
my ball whoa mine mine greedy I got it
all mine oh yeah you almost died there
huh man this is really tough kind of the
best strategy might just be a nice
defensive pattern just kind of swing
swung in as much as you can swung swing
and hope the lag doesn't cause you to
die we're in a dance of death ah no yes
I got you somehow I thought I was doomed
and yet it was you that was the one that
was doomed okay here we go
epic yes I'm so big look at my ball look
how huge it is it is it is kind of a
good strategy just to push it oh oh that
guy's big that guy's big I'm sure that
I'm sure that I'm not original in in the
making of the testicular joke holes here
I'm pretty sure that me as a as a joke a
yokel here ain't too clever
pretty sure anyway alright that's enough
of that um let's see if we can get
another one that we can we can
definitely not accidentally start
streaming all right so this one's called
little big snake which I imagine in some
kind of slow very oh I'm not a hundred
percent sure Conrado that's not there's
no name mark oh okay it is slow very oh
oh well that's just gosh darn cute
I don't like that kind of like that at
all I don't know what that is but I
don't like you
what's with the bugs do I eat the bugs
if the bugs good or the bugs food for me
or they bad I don't know oh that's a
whoa whoa eh whoa eh whoa whoa whoa whoa
easy there I'm just a little baby snake
here I just getting started so you can
sprint much like a slow very Oh with the
bugs
what's with the bugs the bugs ain't
right that's not right now man I'm
ranked 380 third well that's not good at
all there's a there's a dude about I
don't know I don't know about those guys
those guys seem bad also this map seems
huge oh come on no I had a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I had I thought I had him I thought they
were gonna be super confident and not
expect me to make a maneuver and then I
was gonna make a maneuver and they're
gonna be super what that the bug just
sprint into the ocean I guess so yeah I
don't know about these games is why they
can't add sound effects that seems like
a pretty common oversight in these games
is almost none of them have any sort of
sound effects and sound is a big
experience in a game like sound is a
major proponent it doesn't matter what
game it is sound is essential gotta have
sound whoo I am going faster whoo I'm so
fast oh I'm so fast oh sweet I'm all
water speeded up
I don't know what I don't know what kind
of crack is in this water but it's
awesome man I'm flying through this let
me snort some of more of this water
that's good stuff give me that speed all
right I'm big enough to try to fight
some people oh I'm ready I don't know
what this is all about hmm why is there
a Trail of Tears here well that's not
good that's a brick that's a big snack I
ate that snack pack the bargain oh god
that's a big snake is so big so big
it's a big snack oh my god it's
terrifying it's terrifying all right let
me just Miska doodle on out of here
[ __ ] [ __ ]
all right back into the grind I guess
yes yes yes all mine all mine oh my baby
Oh totally stole that right under your
nose
ha ha ha ha now who is the big snack
with the stolen nectar it's me it's me
I'm so long and girthy wah ha ha ha ha I
don't feel good about it
[Music]
yes yes yes yes ha ha ha you fell into
my trap and then you died it's just like
so many people are so ingrained in this
game it would be nearly impossible to
kid like you'd have to play this for
freakin hours to be able to get any sort
of meaningful meaningful score on the
leaderboard I'm 146 this is usually what
these games start out as no Jose what
are you doing Hosie no no no ho Z that's
right no no don't don't even try it
Hosie oh I'm in the thick of the
competition now well so long as I don't
get outplayed by Zoe I should be fine
and if I stay away from all the high
scores which I think the Crown's on the
mini-map are definitely the people of
the highest score here so stay away from
them I should be okay the key to this
game has got to be patience timing slow
procedural steel slow procedural
stealing of everybody else's hard work
that's what I am all about baby
hmm what you think you're doing over the
wall that's skill we look yeah that's
skill we all right apparently I killed
someone I just got another kill and I
don't know where it happened Oh someone
got sandwiched oh hello friend you know
what no no no no let's not do this I'm
gonna say no to this okay there's the
tail-end to somebody beefy I don't like
it but there's there they are
oh I'm heading straight into the crown
territory
how could I be this beefy oh hi Pat how
can I be this beefy and I'm still ranked
79th oh my god what the hell how did
that why do you have so many bugs inside
of you that's a problem
oh well problem for another day 66 I'm
doing great but I sailed right past 69
so what is even the point anymore oh
[ __ ]
someone really got the goods oh no
someone's real again baby over there
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god oh my god no
not today Jim not today Jim you've been
[ __ ] that's so embarrassing oh no
that's so embarrassing I was killed by
Jim I'm so embarrassed
oh if anything I expected it so the fact
that I got to where I was pretty good
okay all right so that is a bunch of Io
games not bad they've kind of evolved
they've kind of devolved they've kind of
side volved but either way there's a lot
of i/o games out there so if you want to
play something for yourself check the
links in the description I provided to
all the ones that I've played and to the
website where I found all these they're
all free to some extent and they're
mostly fun so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what your
favorite IO game down is the comment
blue row let me know your favorite IO
game is down in the
comments below and thanks again for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]